well first of all I was very pleased
that we'd had just before pmqs that she
will be going to Sean Mo shake for the
next cop meeting
um I think that's really important and
and um I know we've got lots of issues
domestically but I'm really glad he went
there and I was glad that he confirmed
very clearly that in his view we can't
have that long-term Prosperity that he
is so focused on if we don't also focus
on climate change and that is the big
picture is that's so important for our
long-term future so I was very pleased
that he was so clear with that
commitment
do you have concerns about how seriously
this Administration does take climate
change and coming off the back of Boris
Johnson who made it such a key part of
his uh Premiership uh Rishi sunak has
said that you know he's going to u-turn
on the policy from this trust to have
more unsure wind farms in a time of
austerity potentially with spending
carts fiscal constraints do you think it
might slip down the agenda under Rishi
sunak
well I think it's really important that
it doesn't slip down the agenda and I
had a chance to speak to the Prime
Minister again immediately after pmqs
and he was very clear that he doesn't
want to slip down the agenda we've
obviously got a lot of domestic
challenges on our economy but so do
other countries across the world
um and so I'm very glad he is going to
cop that's a sign that it won't be
slipping down the agenda and we need to
keep focused on that we you know we need
energy security to have energy security
we need the focus on Renewables I think
many of us who are interested in climate
issues were also very pleased that he
had
um taken fracking off the table and made
it very clear that we shouldn't be doing
that we need to focus on the cleaner
Greener Renewables as well
say that you're very glad that he is
going to go to the cop climate change
Summit that shows that he's taking it
seriously
some would say that what it really shows
is that he doesn't want to be upstaged
by Boris Johnson do you think the timing
of that's a bit strange you know he only
said he was going after Boris Johnson
said he was
I think you know everybody wants a prime
minister to be in 50 million different
places at once and they can't be
everywhere and obviously he's taken over
very very recently only last week at a
time when we need a lot of focus on our
own economy and we're waiting of course
for the economic statement so it is
absolutely right that he's spent time uh
this week really focusing on that and
I'm glad that she's therefore now in a
position to be going off to meet other
world leaders and and that's where he
will be he will be reasonably other
world leaders who are there in Egypt
next week I do want to if I may ask you
a question about the story that we are
leading on today which is the
immigration uh scenes that we're seeing
at the number of small boats crossing
the channels and of course the home the
I was going to say homes actually there
but the immigration Minister I should
say Robert generic uh confirming to me
today that there will be a judicial
review into conditions at manston
How concerned are you about what is
happening
well I think you know it is really
concerning and it's really difficult and
it's a huge number of people which is
putting huge pressure on all sorts of
different local services but I also
think it's another reason why we need to
look at the long-term causes of why
people are leaving different countries I
mean when I was in the Hall of Africa
two weeks ago you know what I saw was
just devastating I mean we've heard
about droughts in Ethiopia in the past
of course but nothing like what's
happening now it's the worst in at least
the past 40 years and where you have
like these climate impacts sometimes
with conflict impacts you then do get
instability that causes migration that
impacts on us back at home and that's
why it's also so important that we
remember that for our own security and
stability at home we need to be
investing in support and development of
other countries too